Телеканал "112 Україна", NewOne, ZIK.
Три загальноукраїнські телеканали зникли з ефіру майже одночасно.
Уперше в Україні ЗМІ звинуватили у пропаганді на користь Росії - країни агресора,
а також у підтримці тероризму і загрозі для національної безпеки України.
Президент Зеленський своїм наказом ввів у дію рішення РНБО про застосування санкцій.
Каналам заборонили користуватися радіочастотним ресурсом України та заблокували їхні активи.
Санкції запроваджені і проти близького соратника кума Путіна Віктора Медведчука - народного депутата від ОПЗЖ Тараса Козака,
номінального власника телеканалів NewsOne, ZIK та 112, які в Україні називають "медіаімперією Медведчука".
Відключені телеканали у спільній заяві назвали санкції проти них "політичною розправою над неугодними ЗМІ"
і не погоджуються зі звинуваченнями у інформаційному тероризмі на користь Росії.
Ведучий телеканалу ZIK Ростислав Сухачев зізнався DW, що рішення про закриття каналів стало шоком для працівників.
Обставини, які начебто зазначаються в революційній частині про якусь терористичну діяльність, то я можу сказати,
що журналісти ZIK, 112 та NewsOne - ми не торгуємо з терористами, ми не продаємо нікому вугілля,
ми не торгували цукерками з Москвою і контрабандою не постачали російські деталі для українського Укроборонпрому за завищеною ціною.
Тому ми би хотіли отримати справедливість і ми на неї розраховуємо.  І сподіваємося, що в Україні ще є закон і порядок.
Ведучий телеканалу ZIK закидає владі утиски свободи слова і свободи преси, які не припустимі в країні, що обрала проєвропейський курс розвитку.
Однак таку позицію поділяє лише меншість у медіаспільноті України.
Представниця міжнародної організації "Репортери без кордонів" Оксана Романюк вважає, що відключені канали,
особливо останнім часом, перетворилися на рупор партії ОПЗЖ і дозволяли собі багато такого, що можна розцінити як російську пропаганду.
Але інформаційна політика каналів, на думку Романюк, навряд чи стала головною причиною рішення РНБО,
що було ухвалене на підставі зібраних СБУ даних, які ще не оприлюднені.
Якщо ці телеканали справді фінансувалися через ці схеми, тоді це все взагалі не про свободу слова.
Якщо говорити про інформаційну політику цих телеканалів, то це однозначно просування прокремлівських наративів,
це численні псевдоексперти проплачені.
Рішення президента Зеленського експерт Центру Разумкова Олексій Мельник вважає чи не єдиним за останній час,
що було ухвалено на захист національних інтересів України.
На думку експерта, інформаційна політика каналів вже давно вийшла за рамки журналістських стандартів.
90 відсотків правди і 10 відсотків - це коли вкраплюються наративи, задля яких дійсно працює канал.
Все, що закидають цим каналам, - це підрив суверенітету, підрив авторитету влади, просування російських наративів,
сумніви щодо того, хто є агресором, - все це здійснювалося досить акуратно, майстерно, технологічно,
все впліталося в той контекст новин, які , якщо не звертати увагу на ті пропагандистські меседжі,
є абсолютно об’єктивними стосовно проблем економічних, суспільних, стосовно критики влади.
Це дуже небезпечні канали. Вони небезпечні тим, що позиціонувалися, як українські.
Національна спілка журналістів України згодна з тим, що українські ЗМІ не мають бути рупором російської пропаганди.
Однак відключення телеканалів тут називають надзвичайною ситуацією і заявляють, що не можуть погодитися з методами,
якими держава хоче усунути ризики для національної безпеки.
Фактично, ідеться про те, що понад 1300 журналістів і співробітників вказаних телеканалів
на сьогодні через санкції отримали заборону на професію, заборону на своє майбутнє в ЗМІ.
При тому, що в нас відсутня інформація про те, що хоч один з тележурналістів, ведучих є фігурантом кримінальних проваджень,
де доведена якась підривна діяльність.
Тому виходить, що журналісти покарані при тому, що персональна їхня вина ніде не доведена. Це прецедент.
Думки українців щодо відключення каналів, яких звинувачують у російській пропаганді, теж розділилися.
Максимально позитивно. Тому що вони є рупором пропаганди, яку веде проти нас РФ в інформаційній війні.
Вони намагаються зробити рейтинг своїй партії ОПЗЖ.
Ставимося не дуже позитивно, тому що ми за свободу преси. А до Медведчука дуже негативно ставимося.
Але свободу пресі в будь-якому випадку!
Дуже погано! Чому? Нема що дивитися!
Підтримую. Давно пора було. Сподіваюся, ми побачимо подання СБУ. Фінансування тероризму, як ходять чутки, це злочин, який має бути покараний.
Якщо ми живемо в демократичній державі, то кожна людина має право вільно висловити свою думку.
Це демонстративне рішення, яке не робить нам честі.
Юристи телеканалів вже заявили про те, що оскаржуватимуть рішення РНБО і наказ президента в суді.
Головний аргумент - закон про санкції не може бути застосований до ЗМІ, РНБО не може втручатися в роботу телеканалів,
оскільки головним регулятором ринку є Національна рада з питань телебачення і радіомовлення.
Саме Нацрада може відкликати ліцензію, встановлювати порушення, штрафувати тощо.
Нацрада неодноразово критикувала роботу телеканалів і навіть робила спроби відкликати ліцензії, але поки безуспішно.
Юрист Інституту масової інформації Роман Головенко згоден з тим, що влада має реагувати на прояви пропаганди з боку Росії,
але погоджується також і з тим, що реагувати на роботу українських ЗМІ має насамперед Нацрада.
Юрист уже бачить певні правові колізії такого рішення, якщо телеканали, приміром, подадуть позов до Європейського суду з прав людини.
У нас є Конвенція прав людини і основоположних свобод, стаття 10-та.
І однозначно вимкнення телеканалів буде розглядатися, як втручання в роботу приватних суб’єктів.
І держава повинна буде обґрунтувати, що було втручання, що передбачене законом, що була легітимна мета.
Але найголовніше те, що треба буде обґрунтувати, що це було необхідним у демократичному суспільстві.
У даному випадку, що це було співставно із загрозами
й було обрано найм’якший засіб з усіх можливих у формі такого обмеження свободи слова.
Юрист вважає, що застосування санкцій проти телеканалів свідчить насамперед про пасивну роботу Нацради,
яка мала втрутитися в ситуацію раніше. Якщо ж власники телеканалів пов’язані з Росією і ведуть незаконну діяльність,
то СБУ вже давно мала порушити проти них кримінальні справи, надати докази тощо.
З цим погоджуються і в німецькій журналістській мерЕжі n-ost, що спеціалізується на Східній Європі.
В інтерв’ю DW її представник заявив, що забороні каналів мала передувати суспільна і правова дискусія
про дотримання телеканалами журналістських стандартів.
Це мала б супроводжувати дискусія у ЗМІ та суспільстві, аби було зрозуміло, чому саме це пропаганда, були наведені докази.
Цього всього, на мою думку, не відбулося. Питання викликає також і часовий аспект.
Чому Зеленський не зробив це набагато раніше?
Багато хто каже, що це пов'язано з внутрішньополітичними мотивами, тим, що рівень підтримки його партії падає,
а близької до заборонених телеканалів політсили ОПЗЖ зростає. Усе це має неприємний присмак.
За висновками німецького експерта, відключення трьох телеканалів без жодних попередніх оголошень
може мати довгострокові наслідки для свободи слова в Україні.
Для свободи слова і думки буде великою проблемою, якщо всі просто сприймуть це як належне.
Адже це означатиме, що влада тепер зможе закрити й інші телеканали, якщо захоче. Або наступна влада зможе це зробити.
Секретар РНБО Данилов вже заявив про те, що в Україні є ще багато ЗМІ, які займаються російською пропагандою.
Це означає, що долю ZIK, NewsOne та 112-того можуть повторити інші масмедіа.
Однак без ретельного юридичного обґрунтування таких санкційних рішень влади
заборона ЗМІ з точки зору демократії - вкрай небезпечний шлях.